So, whenever an interviewer contacts you to tell you that you haven't been successful,...
...always reply but be positive.
We need to demonstrate to them that they have missed out,...
...that you are the professional person.
You are mature.
But, that you also understand that you weren't the right person for their organization...
...at that particular time.
But, you need to say to them:...
"...Thank you very much for contacting me...
...and for giving me the opportunity to be interviewed for the position.
Whilst I am disappointed,...
...I understand that I wasn't the right person at this particular time."
However, if you change your mind...
...or if it doesn't work with the other person you have chosen,...
...please do not hesitate to get back in touch with me...
...because I genuinely want to work for your organization."
If you said that to me when I turned you down for a job,...
...I would think to myself: "Wow, this person really is professional!"
And if it didn't work out with the person I'd chosen, I would come back to you.
And the thing to remember is this does happen.
It might not work out with the person they've chosen...
...and they might come back to you, so always be professional.
Never demonstrate any form of anger, frustration or negativity...
...when responding to a job interview rejection.